says Keith Richards says you know ten
percent or ninety percent of everything
is crap
hi I'm Nicolas booth reason TV and today
we're talking with Kurt Loder the author
of the good the bad and the god-awful
21st century movie reviews Kurt thanks
for talking to us he reviews movies from
recent calm and Creators Syndicate he
had a long stint at MTV reviewing movies
for them occurred in reading the book
the first thing that struck a popped out
to me is that most of these reviews are
negative are you just a movie hater
no no I love movies I think you know as
with anything else good movies are more
rare than the bad ones because the the
pipeline has to be filled you have to
push stuff out there always must be
movies on the way so none of them are
gonna be good yeah Keith Richards says
you know 10% or 90% of everything is
crap right so let's talk about the 21st
century movie reviews give us a couple
of examples of movies that you think are
really good I really like zodiac which
is a great David Fincher movie and it's
about the zodiac killings in San
Francisco at the end of the 1960's and
the amazing thing about the movie is
there's so much information and it's two
and a half hours long and the case was
never solved and yet he brings it to a
satisfying conclusion it's just an
amazing piece of work by a great
director I think what are another movie
that you've found particularly memorable
and possibly under under appreciated I
think in Bruges is a really really good
movie that no one's seen there's a movie
called the Brothers Bloom that was done
by Rian Johnson who did brick it's a
fantasy movie it came out I've got no
promotion and yet it's really really
good what are the what are two or three
bad movies that really stand out
Australia is a really bad movie is it
costs a lot of money obviously and it's
it's kind of a about Australia but it's
actually a Western there's a cowboy
there's a feisty Widow there's a cattle
baron so it's indistinguishable more a
Western and it goes on and on and on
you're going to mumble it in and then it
it turns into another kind of movie a
World War 2 movie and your heart just
sinks you know because it won't stop and
it's just one of those movies you go why
was it made what were you thinking you
know it's just it's battling Golden
Compass was god I wonder if anybody
remember
I'm sure that newline thought you know
after the Lord of the Rings will take
this sort of semi famous trilogy His
Dark Materials we're gonna make it into
a franchise they make the first one and
it was it was just awful oh so bad so
that's a good that's a market success
story though right because when we don't
have to take our kids you devote an
entire section of the good the bad and
the guys awful to Nicholas Cage why he
is an entire section to himself as a guy
who's he comes from a filmmaking family
the coke boys and he's such a good actor
as we know he's a really good actor but
his decisions about what movies to make
ghostwriter you know like why why are
you doing this and yet he still is
acting yeah he doesn't it just doesn't
just blow it off he throws himself into
it I'm giving a performance and you got
to admire that you know it's kind of
this movie sucks but Nick you know
there's been a breakup of kind of mass
markets I mean it's you know the number
one movie today the number one TV show
the number one bestseller does not sell
as many copies generally or hold as big
a percentage of its audience as they did
20 30 50 years ago is that a good thing
or a bad thing do you think mm-hmm
I mean maybe it's a good thing in that
more more movies get made but there are
more outlets for for independent
filmmakers you can do more you can get
it on video you can go on cable TV
there's special channels they'll handle
that so it's a great thing for young
filmmakers and the audience is bound to
fragment unless there's one unifying
thing avatar seem to unify a lot of
people not me but you know people just
loved it and I think it was just doing
softening the ground for the Smurfs
movie the blue-skinned Kurt Loder movie
reviewer for reason.com for creator
syndicate and the author of the great
new collection the good the bad and the
god-awful
21st century movie reviews